[Applaudissements]
avez-vu un rêve lorsque vous étiez jeune
un rêve que vous vouliez
réaliser moi j'avais un rêve lorsque
j'avais 12 ans je voulais créer un jeu
vidéo j'ai été voir trois
potes et on s'est lancé cet objectif on
a commencé à apprendre un langage de
programmation et
rapidement on a vu que c'était bien
galère et même si ce jeu vidéo il a
jamais vu le jour il m'a permis de
trouver ma voix puisque quelques années
plus tard je rentrais à l'ut
informatique de Paris
Descartes aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous
parler d'un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur
et qui a profondément impacté mon
parcours
d'étudiant le sujet c'est comment l'état
d'esprit entrepreneurial peut-il être le
meilleur atout des
étudiants pu donc rentrer dans mes
études supérieures et j'ai appris à
développer des sites Web des
applications au fond de moi je savais
que c'est pas ce que je voulais faire de
toute ma vie les sites web les applis
c'est cool mais ce qui me passionne
réellement c'est de mettre mes
compétences au service de projets et de
causes qui me
plaisent et en y
réfléchissant avec des sites Web et des
applis on peut changer le monde qui nous
entoure et c'est vraiment ça qui me
plaît lors de mes études sur Paris je me
levais tôt le dimanche matin pour aller
chiner des jeux vidéos en
videgrenier je les revendais un peu plus
cher sur Internet Inter et c'était un
moyen pour moi de me faire un peu
d'argent de poche pour payer ma vie
parisienne et vous me voyez peut-être
venir mais j'ai eu une idée je me suis
dit bah pourquoi pas créer ma propre
plateforme d'achat et de vente de jeux
vidéo et donc je me suis lancé avec
Tommy un ami de l'UT et voici en trois
étapes comment nous nous y sommes
pris premièrement
nous avons créé le site web avec de
nombreuses fonctionnalités et sans avoir
testé le besoin des clients
ensuite nous avons créé la
société et finalement on a été chercher
des vendeurs des
acheteurs on s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait passé beaucoup de temps à
développer des fonctionnalités qui
n'était pas
utilisé que les besoins et les
problématiques des vendeurs c'étaaiit
pas du tout celles auquell on avait
pensé et pourtant on avait déjà dépensé
du temps de l'argent et beaucoup
d'énergie dans le
projet après un peu plus d'un an de
travail nous avions réalisé un bénéfice
record de 12
€ alors avec
Tommy on est allé s'acheter un
kebab et on a fermé la société
vous vous demandez peut-être mais
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'on a créé ce
projet de cette
manière et bien parce que avec Tommy on
était avant tout des étudiants
passionnés et que ce projet c'était une
excellente manière de mettre en pratique
ce qu'on apprenait à l'école mais
c'était absolument pas une bonne manière
pour créer une entreprise viable
économiquement de plus
la peur de l'échec nous a poussé à
continuer à bosser sur notre produit sur
notre site Web alors que nous auons dû
le confronter à nos acheteurs à nos
vendeurs cette peur de l'échec c'est
quelque chose qui est ancré en
nous depuis qu'on est petit à l'école on
nous apprend qu'avoir une bonne note
c'est réussir avoir une mauvaise note
c'est un
échec avec des mauvaises notes on
redouble avec des mauvaises notes on ne
peut pas faire ce qu'on veut dans la
vie suis sûr que ça vous est déjà arrivé
repenseer à une situation une situation
que vous avez vécu une situation d'échec
et qui s'est transformé des semaines des
mois des années plus tard en
réussite ça c'est ce qui arrivver à un
certain Walter Disney alors je vais pas
vous raconter l'histoire de Walt Disney
pense que vous la connaissez aussi bien
que moi mais connaissez-vous l'histoire
de Walter avant d'avoir créé son
empire Walter il travaillait pour un
journal aux
États-Unis lorsqu'il était jeune et il
s'est fait renvoyer pour manque
d'imagination et de
créativité il a ensuite créé plusieurs
sociétés qui ont toutes déposé le bilan
et Walter il s pas arrêter là Walter il
a continué à persévérer il a appris de
ses
échecs pour créer ce qu'on connaît tous
Aujourd'hui j'ai continué mon parcours
d'étudiant en école
d'ingénieur et la dernière année de mes
études le covid est
arrivé
rappelez-vous nous sommes le 16 mars
2020 et c'est le début du premier conf
ement une telle situation vient
bouleverser le quotidien de T les
Français une telle situation ça implique
de nouveaux problèmes dans la société et
un problème c'est une opportunité de
créer de nouvelles solutions un problème
c'est une opportunité de créer de
nouvelles
solutions 3 jours avant le début du
confinement j'étais dans un bar avec des
potes on buvait un coup 3 jours plus
tard nous n'étions plus certains de
retrouver ce bar ouvert à la sortie du
confinement les bars il devaient
continuer à payer des factures d'eau
d'électricité de
loyer et pourtant du jour au lendemain
il n'avaiit plus aucun revenu parce
qu'ils étaient fermés et donc les
établissements qui étaient en galère
financière au début du confinement bah
il se retrouvaiit un peu dans dans la
panade
si le confinement durait trop longtemps
ils allaient devoir mettre la clé sous
la
porte et donc 2 jours après le début du
confinement avec avec un ami nous avons
lancé la première version de sauver mon
bar pour aider les bars dans un premier
temps puis les restaurants à générer du
chiffre d'affaires pendant la
crise et le concept il était tout simple
les clients
acheter des bons
d'achat avec une petite réduction de
leur bar ou leur restaurant les patrons
ils avaient donc de la trésorerie
pendant le confinement pour pouvoir
payer leur factur et il s'assuraient
d'avoir de la clientèle à leur
réouverture puisque les clients
viendraient consommer avec les bons
d'achat avec sauvé monbard sur les trois
premiers mois de confinement nous avons
pu aider plus d'une centaine de bars et
de restaurants en France et leur avons
reversé plus de 20000
€ et si on remarque la différence avec
ma première entreprise elle est
flagrante avec sauvé mon bar on est
parti d'un problème à un moment donné et
on a répondu très rapidement avec une
solution nous avons ensuite essayé de
transformer sauver monb bar en
entreprise en apportant de nouveaux
services digitaux au patrons de bar et
de
restaurant pendant des mois nous avons
créé ces nouveau service sans pour
autant réussir à générer assez de
bénéfices pour pouvoir en vivre et
quelques semaines plus tard nous avons
décidé d'arrêter de travailler sur le
projet et avec du
recul une grande qualité nous a manqué
avec sauvé monb et cette qualité c'est
la
patience nous voulions avoir des
résultats trop
rapidement nous n'avons pas pris le
temps d'éduquer les patrons de bar et de
restaurant à nos nouveaux services nous
n'avons pas pris le temps de changer
notre image de
marque la patience c'est une qualité qui
est extrêmement importante dans un monde
où on est habitué à avoir tout à la
demande à commander un objet sur
Internet et le recevoir le lendemain au
pied de sa
porte la patience c'est souvent quelque
chose qu'on
oublie et la réussite ça prend du du
temps il aura fallu plus de 7 ans à JK
rolling que son œuvre Harry Potter ne
soit disponible en
librairie au départ il y avait aucune
maison d'édition qui voulait de son
livre jackma le fondateur
d'Alibaba c'est pareil c'est quelqu'un
qui a eu un long parcours difficile et
lorsquil cré Alibaba ça fonctionne pas
en claquant des doigts il lui a fallu
plus de 3 ans pour pour générer du
bénéfice au cours des différents projets
que j'ai mené j'ai pu apprendre
plusieurs qualités de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un état d'esprit entrepreneurial
des qualités comme le passage à
l'action la patience la
persévérance l'apprentissage des échecs
ces qualités elles m'ont été grandement
utiles pendant mes études mais aussi sur
mes nouveaux projets d'aujourd'hui
ces qualités elles m'ont permis de
prendre confiance en moi de me fixer des
objectifs et de trouver ma
voix vous vous souvenez de ce jeu vidéo
que je voulais créer quand j'avais 12
ans et bien je ne savais pas à l'époque
mais l'important c'est pas d'avoir
réussi à créer jeux vidéo l'important
c'est bien le passage à l'action entre
l' idée et sa
réalisation puisque même si nous n'avons
pas été au bout c'est ce qui m'a permis
de trouver ma voix parsemer d'échecs de
réussite que j'ai réussi à transformer
en
apprentissage que ce soit dans
l'entrepreneuriat dans les études ou
dans la vie orurel San avait raison ce
qui compte c'est pas l'arrivée c'est la
quête merci
[Applaudissements]